that's what we've been waiting for Nina
this is all we been waiting for lesson
of the day if you wake up at 5:00 when
you have neighbors make sure you play
your news really loudly I finish the
book like it's an awesome book
[Music]
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello
it's alright Liat see we got up we're
about the head to breakfast how'd you
sleep Nina it's okay
okay to something and another time at
5:00 because people are they
lesson of the day if you wake up at five
then you have neighbors make sure you
play your news really loudly so you can
make their day so hey if I'm starting
today le everybody else is going to
we're gonna eat even is gonna work out
and work on my book I don't know I don't
want to work out this early I want it I
got a drive heart I want to get my book
that I'm gonna get at least a hundred
pages done today
at least a hundred pages let's do it
so can you see this face no beard comes
Darren thanks dad
we want the beard people want the beard
back alright here's my round one and
then gentlemen be getting it just last
time I spilled everything on myself oh
that's a big breakfast
the big bad girl is a cute girl look at
our windows type suit what are you doing
[Music]
oh you just eat the yolk on it and then
you need the whites later
[Music]
thank you seen way to eat Thanks stop it
don't pop it all right breakfast is done
feeling good how you feeling full too
full
not too cold good we're gonna head to
the library quickly I want to see some
other non-fiction books and just see if
I listen anything from my book at any
inspiration ideas that I need the pile
into the book besides just work on the
content I already have and then we have
our passports and then write the book I
need a workout yeah yeah it's cold let's
do it
it's a happy day arm that boat
[Music]
so after looking at the books if you
like I'm not really missing that much
for my book if anything I feel like I'm
not missing anything feel like it's an
awesome book now you got to go finish
writing it let's do it let's do it
[Music]
eight Florentina all you want get the
passport passport
all right before sit down the right you
know they're gonna get a large
cappuccino each our spots are empty
that's where I'm going to be writing
from pretty good spot overlooking the
atrium
maybe we'll get some live music
happening and some serious progress in
the life here we are this is where the
magic happens
[Music]
they're setting up the cake making
demonstration you got a pretty good seat
boy out here Nina's gonna watch I'm
gonna hit work right now sit in that
cage 3:14 let's go go go alright we're
gonna take the lean on Evans show
outside
Nina's passing out because it's too dark
and I'm getting a headache because it's
too dark so we're gonna go outside and
be woken up by the fresh air and
sunshine fresh air wakes you up huh lots
of food look at this
salmon chowder give it a try Neiman
alright
[Music]
I think we found it peach cobbler and
caramel thighs very excited with a lunch
cobbler with caramel sauce and ice cream
on top with my coffee and pretzels it's
quality lunch right there that's what
you need to write an effective book
[Music]
all right setup got my pretzels got my
coffee got the laptop
what's unlocking where we take 3:45
let's go go go go go go go
here comes the wife she's very special
oh wow look what she got I'm just gonna
be some yummy stuff who do we love we
love Nina she's so special you guys
should all give me an I round of
applause in the comments because she's
giving me the fuel to make this amazing
book for you I might Nina
boom right now page 381 we're getting
closer we're getting closer friends even
is starting to feel a little bit queasy
so we're gonna go back to the bedroom
she's gonna lie down and I'm gonna keep
working on the book
[Music]
I finished the book for 29.4 29
[Laughter]
there's still some formatting and other
things that have to get done but I am
super pumped we are getting close to
launching this thing and I am excited
all right finish the review of the first
drop super excited about that high-five
to me yeah
Nina is very excited too she slept
through most of it but woke up just in
time
Nina's gonna go work it I'm gonna go get
some salty food we reapplied the juice
the juice the serum the formula the oil
I don't know I still feel seasick and I
was working that's it
really I'm not gonna be skeptical I'm
gonna be a believer I'm gonna get some
salty foods if that helps Nina's gonna
go crush it on the workhead and then
we're going to have French restaurant
dinner tonight that would be stroke he
was gonna get some escargot and some
French onion soup another food she's
very excited okay Nina have a great
workout we'll see you later
we love you believe nation loves you bye
Nina we love you
all right so I got some pizzas and chips
get me some salt
and that hope to make the head feel
better YouTube is finally working on the
boat to start and watch Lily's video and
give her some feedback she's doing a TED
talk first TED talk coming up soon so
giving her some feedback I'm so excited
for her
the wife is back how did you do that's
good into what an hour 70 minutes holy
cow wife is on how do you feel hungry
you went to get food remember we have we
have French restaurant are you serious
hey nice goin inna on fire maybe we'll
see okay shower then dinner then then
we'll see
all right it's time to hit up the French
bistro for dinner I was feeling a little
queasy but Nina put the juice on me oh
yeah yo high up in that actually it's
kind of working out I was very skeptical
about that I'm a hashtag believer now
we're going lower nice let's wavy down
there Oh Nina's all dressed up hello
fiery Jason I'm all dressed up fella
wearing a airplane t-shirt
we've been looking forward to this
dinner for awhile especially for Nina
get her escargot and French onion soup
I'm a mom and then that probably hit up
the buffet for dessert afterwards
although I had a kind of ice cream today
pretty that was pretty exciting saucy
I'm having some Emperor's nectar yeah
champagne happy last dinner oh that's
good oh the cinnamon is good nice
so what you've been waiting for Nina
this is what we've been waiting for how
it looks cheesy it looks hot nice
[Music]
alright I am so full who's winning it
darling it's pretty good
who shows that way it's funny that way
we've missed all the shows we do much a
single show except like first day but it
wasn't really a shows like a preview day
so this shows also be the epic show it's
super famous it's what they're known for
so we're gonna see the show no filming
allowed so I can't show you guys so
we're rushing is it starting super get
seats and that we will see you guys on
the other side alright we decided to
abandon the show we gave it 15 minutes
maybe it was okay we were sending up I
could go either way
which isn't a strong endorsement Nina
was not enjoying it
she's like shows you just haven't seen
the right ones and if it was it's dark
in there
listen let's be honest if we had a seat
you would have fallen asleep so what are
we gonna do we're gonna go pack yeah
pack you're gonna work out
[Music]
pack Nina's gonna work out I'm gonna
look up how to get a nice BN number for
my book and see if I can get ahead of
the curve yeah right no I don't want to
- I'm so full
yeah you guys me no no I'm too far yeah
that's wrong you're looking
guys when I'm hot I limp - just just mix
along this listen and being hot is
totally the same thing all right
packing time we leave tomorrow our cap
and stare was cleaning our cabin and we
can't go back to the cabin yet so
neither goes what does that mean what
does that mean it drain it's time for a
drink
Bernina not me I'm done
[Music]
a dinosaur well what else could that be
believe nation what is this trash
giraffe how fat the legs are elephant
the container the head is were the ears
that's a dinosaur you know what kind of
dinosaur it is to believe a Saurus
all right time to pack Nemo let's do it
let's do it Teddy Teddy the belief
asaurus let's pack up
it's last night up our cruise I just
want to see what's on the buffet
all right I realize I haven't posted in
a while I've meant by posted I've made a
video in a while Nina took my phone and
did something so we packed I registered
for the ISBN or my new book I figured
out the whole process on Amazon to
publish Nina's very excited to enjoy
enjoy join into the video sentiment the
same with her thumb okay okay we see
your thumb peace and love
thank you guys for joining us for
another day in the next video we lain
back in London and start to explore and
have some fun thank you for joining us
hope you have an amazing weekend we
believe in you we have continued to
believe in yourself and whatever your
when where it is much love you know see
you soon